entering his sixth year now in the
national football league fresh off of a
big win against kansas city getting set
to take on the raiders on monday night
football is
from the los angeles charges joey bosa
how are you joey i'm good it's crazy
when you you're here six years six years
hard to believe why
fast has it gone fast fast
the days are long the years are fast i
i've heard that quote once and i i i
feel like it
explains the season perfectly well
that's that's what people say about
having children joey
um which you know you have not entered
that realm no not not not yet okay very
good at least as i know
[Music]
that is what they say about having kids
i've got three of them and that is
exactly what it is like um
how how are you different though from
when you were in the league six years
ago oh how am i different i mean at the
core of i mean who i am i think i'm
obviously the same person but i think
i've learned a lot about myself and
i think i'm just
a better guy
i think i treat people with more respect
i think i'm
trying to be more grateful more thankful
every day and obviously you fluctuate
you have hard times and this and that
but i i just feel like i've grown to
appreciate things and i've learned how
to how to treat treat people especially
close to me um how i really want to and
just
kind of get in control of my mind and my
emotions i can kind of act
the way i i'd want to the way i know i
i'd be proud of rather than kind of
reacting to some things and and
and being uh emotional and and saying
some things that you later on regret
does that make you a better football
player too
yeah
we got deep all of a sudden no no i mean
look
i'll go wherever you want to go joey i
mean you know
let's go i'll follow your lead yeah no i
think it has definitely made me a better
football player um my ability to just
kind of stay in the moment focus on the
next play because i've realized that
good or bad it can suck you up and it
can ruin
maybe not ruin but affect your day
affect the next play because
you go you go out there you have a great
series you get a sack you get a tfo
whatever you're playing great
all right i'm good i'm i'm i'm i'm an
animal i'm playing great the rest of
this game is just going to go
smoothly and that doesn't happen unless
you come to play every single play you
stay in the moment and on the on the
flip side of that you have a bad play
and i i can get in my head a lot and be
like self-doubt this and that you're
trying to over analyze things
and when i'm able to just say all right
forget that what do i have next
um i'm just able to stay in the moment
and be a much more effective player and
that obviously is is the same off the
field with my relationships how big was
that w against kansas city last week oh
it was huge um both one and one uh going
in on the road
i've i haven't played there and with
such nice nice weather yet um so the
time of the year was it was really nice
the grass field was perfect condition
but uh it was just a fun game because it
was
i mean it happened exactly how how coach
was talking uh talking about he said
we're gonna get up on these guys and
when they start making a run that's when
we have to come together and play our
best ball
and as i've seen a million times before
just 14 points isn't enough or even 20
21 points isn't enough to keep these
guys down they usually do a great job
going into the
locker room at halftime and coming out
with a great plan obviously andy reed is
a legend so
we knew the game was far from over after
the half and uh i think it just it
showed a resilience to be able to go
down and then come back make the place
we needed to on defense
we talked all week about getting the
ball and we got it four times and i
think we needed every one of them
so you know joey bosa you might be
breaking news here because one of the
most used coaching cliches from coaches
is i don't have a crystal ball are you
telling me brandon staley has a crystal
ball
he seems like he does sometimes
it might be a secret he just goes and
rubs his crystal ball and his locker in
in the corner and then he's like all
right i got the plan we're gonna get up
on the chiefs they're gonna make a run
and we're gonna stop him and we'll take
the ball away i mean literally you're
saying that's what he mapped out for you
guys yeah he just he just knew i think
like we all did that
once you get up on these guys they
always do a great job of coming back
they you hardly beat them uh i mean when
have they lost by more than a touchdown
or
other than the super bowl obviously but
um
but i mean with a guy like mahomes and
all the all the weapons that they have
you you got to be ready because they can
make a push at any time and they're a
resilient team but uh i just think he
knew that at some point they were going
to get some yards get a big play on us
and that's when we'd need to come
together and really
really shut it down and play as a team
and we and i i believe that it was
really a team win
joey bosa here before monday night
football the chargers taking on the las
vegas raiders right here uh currently on
the rich eisen show so joey um how has
brandon staley
changed things how was how are things
different
than your previous years
oh he's he's he's great um
i'm always hesitant to to trust new
people obviously coming in you learn
through my six years i've also learned
how to be a little uh
hard to uh hard to please with with
something sometimes
um
i've learned to not just obviously trust
people right off the bat it takes time
to build that relationship and uh
i think i mean from day one uh he we
went up into his office and we talked
for about two hours straight uh talked
about his plan for me just about life
about his story and his family
and uh ever since then i feel like he's
just been a genuine uh genuine guy he
i was like man is this an act is he is
he just trying to
uh
i don't know get our get our respect be
be a like liked guy uh no but he's he's
here he's gonna tell you to tell you the
truth he's gonna be who he is
and i just like how he takes control of
the whole team
what's really impressive to me is this
crazy memory i could remember the
specifics of this play this and that and
he's just a he's just a really
knowledgeable guy when it comes to every
position he can go into any any position
room and he could talk football he could
talk technique it's not just oh this
this and that it's it's he knows how to
play football um and it's down to the
technique and
i also like he coached our position so
he can come into our room and he he
really knows how to play that position
and he coached some great players
um but just today even we just we were
getting a little sloppy
and he called us together and it's not a
coach
telling us
he's part we're all part of a unit
and he's like come on guys and he's
building us up and he does a great job
of giving people credit when they when
they deserve it he
today he was showing clips of the scout
team how well they've been doing um i
just think he does a lot of things right
he makes you want to play for him he
makes you want to play hard for him
joey bosa here before monday night
football against the las vegas raiders
and first place online here obviously
the broncos are also 3-0 and they'll
have already played the ravens by the
time you kick off in sofi
uh on monday night and so
uh
what's the challenge here against a a
team that's unblemished and hot with a
quarterback who's amassed the most yards
so far through the first three weeks
joey yeah number one offense monday
night after a big win um another thing
coach staley was talking about is you're
not gonna win this game because you beat
the chiefs last week
you're going to win this game because
you put in a lot of hard work during the
week and you practice really hard and
prepared really well for these guys
so it's something you got to put in
every single day
i think we've done a really good job
this week preparing obviously face car
many times
kind of got a revamp revamped o-line
which will be interesting to see but
they've been doing a great job
they have some great weapons with waller
and renfro
and carr just does a good job of getting
that ball out really quick so it's
another game where we're going to have
to control the pocket obviously they
can't do he can't do the same amount of
damage outside the pocket like a
guy like my homes can
but
it's gonna be a fun challenge uh rookie
right tackle he's been doing a good job
so
it's uh
we think that they're gonna come in here
and try to run the ball uh 30-second run
defense so far
which is not too good out of 32
um
but i think we've we've done a good job
we've obviously prepared for the pass uh
heavily in the last two weeks so
um i think we just have to stop that run
and manage carr and keep them in a tight
pocket and lastly for you joey you got
your own top-notch quarterback clearly
give me a good justin herbert story
obviously you've chased down some of the
best
in the nfl and you practice against this
kid and you see him all the time you got
a good justin herbert story for me yeah
uh i don't know if i have a great story
yet we haven't had too many uh too many
experiences outside of football together
yet but i mean he's just he is
unbelievable but what i love about him
the most is he's just such a humble nice
kid
um i call him a kid he's you're younger
than me but
you've been in the league six years ago
yeah
no but he's uh he's great and like i
said he's so humble it's almost like he
doesn't even know he's such a superstar
um
but it's just so great to have a guy
like that back there when you get a
third and long and in my head i'm like
all right
we're gonna get this like we have a
great chance with a guy like herbert
keane and mike all the weapons that we
have
and i think he's just gonna keep getting
better he has such a strong arm that i
feel like oh he almost throws it too
hard sometimes
and as he gets older it'll it'll refine
that touch and just keep getting smarter
and
to be able to do the things he can on
his legs as well stay on his feet and
kind of make things out of nothing he's
a
i need a next victory i'll definitely be
over there for his victory brisket
i love it well have a great monday
nighter joey uh enjoy that stadium how
great is that stadium how about you
absolutely it's great it's great yeah i
mean i wish it was grass but i'll take
it yeah i know i i hear you but i i mean
just
it's one of the loudest places i've ever
been to
period and yeah hopefully we've got a
good showing out of some some blue and
yellow this week i know the the raiders
fans definitely travel well i've
struggled before that's true well good
luck with that and joey thanks for the
time here have a great monday nighter
and uh let's chat more down the line
definitely thank you have a good one you
got it that's joey bosa right here
before monday night football against the
las vegas raiders
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here